welcome back with covid restrictions
loosening finally people are feeling
more comfortable going out again
but the rape crisis center is already
reporting an increase in sexual assault
exams at area hospitals and predators
are going after the vulnerable so
if you meet someone online during the
pandemic and plan to meet up
some things to keep in mind first meet
in a public place
and share your location with a loved one
second watch your drink do not leave it
unattended
and third have your own transportation
or rideshare do not
accept rides from a stranger or someone
you maybe think you know
human trafficking is still a big issue
here in the valley and many hospitality
workers are trained to help victims
a lot of our security folks especially
in our
in our hospitality corridor have been
trained on
recognizing predatory behavior and
things so
if um you know if folks are ever in a
situation that's making them feel
uncomfortable they should really think
about
using security in these locations as a
resource
here's some more helpful information so
the rape crisis center has a 24-hour
hotline the number is there on the
screen
now they also have a text message line
so if you're in a dangerous situation
and can't speak
you can text that number the one it's
the third one listed
and they even have an online chat
available now on their website it's
rcclv.org we have all this information
for you on our website so please be
careful